this is boeing's 737 and this
is the airbus a320 they're by far the
most popular passenger planes sold
around the world
with over a fifth of them flying in
china making it a key market
this is a continuation of a long-term
strategy of airbus in china
but these two rivals may soon have a new
direct competitor
the c919 made by chinese state-owned
aviation company comac
these planes are expected to enter into
service later this year
and state-owned airlines in china have
already ordered or expressed interest
in more than 1 000 of them komak is
owned and heavily subsidized by beijing
and that makes the company potentially
the biggest challenge to a duopoly that
has dominated the market
for over three decades i'm looking
forward to
talking to you all the rise of china's
aviation industry is one big reason why
the us
and the european union have called the
truce on a 17-year tariff fight
over government subsidies others are
taking the opportunity
to launch their own industries and we
have been too busy
fighting each other to pay attention so
how can airbus and boeing counter comac
technology their global reach and
growing political support
could be some of the answers
boeing and airbus have been rivals since
the 1960s back then
the european company was seen as an
overly subsidized laggard but after 1988
airbus a320 allowed it to knock boeing
off the top spot
several times so facing new competition
boeing
nudged the us to start a legal fight in
2004
and then the eu has today decided to
take
the united states to the world trade
organization over the massive subsidies
they give
to boeing it became the longest and most
costly battle
in the history of the world trade
organization resulting in more than a
billion dollars in tariffs
lately airbus has pulled ahead of boeing
in terms of orders that's also because
boeing has been dealing with a major
crisis
since the grounding of its 737 max
planes after a string of crashes
all of us feel the immense gravity of
these events across our company
the coronavirus pandemic has also hit
both companies
hard with both delivering hundreds fewer
planes
but there's one market that wasn't doing
as badly china
at one point china became the world's
largest
aviation market as the u.s canceled
flights
now the u.s and europe have decided to
suspend their trade fight to work
together
and focus on china to confront the
threat
from china's ambitions to build an
aircraft sector eros told us that comac
could take a share of the single ill
market by the end of the decade
and in china that direct competition is
about to start
since 2008 comic alone has received
between
49 and 72 billion dollars in government
aid
according to industry watchers and has
successfully built a regional plane
the arj21 the c919 has cost between
9 to 20 billion dollars to develop it's
designed to directly compete with narrow
body planes like the 737
and the a320 which can handle a range of
short
and medium-haul routes the chinese
aircraft is less fuel efficient
has a shorter range and lacks the global
service network of the western plain
makers
but china alone will need some 8600
planes
over the next 20 years according to
boeing i believe their need
for aircraft is significant and coolmak
wants to provide many of those orders
for western planes from chinese airlines
are much lower than what demand would
suggest
indicating that they may plan to buy the
c919 instead
china and russia are now also developing
the cr929
a long-haul wide-body aircraft that
should start being built this year
so how could airbus and boeing counter
comac well
first there is manufacturing boeing has
been developing planes for over a
century
and relies on decades of experience and
intellectual property to deploy the
latest plane technology
comac is some 90 years younger than
boeing and its c919
has already faced production delays it
will initially only be able to produce
very few c919s
each month boeing and airbus have also
used their duopoly to create an
international network of parts
servicing and mechanics to ensure their
planes can operate around the globe even
if comax planes become successful in
china
they might be hard to export and then
there is concessions
airbus has already received around 13
billion dollars in pandemic bailout
support which it is partly investing
into researching hydrogen planes
one particular technology pathway which
we find
most promising is hydrogen boeing an
airbus's newfound truce could help them
pose legal challenges to comac
while still trying to extract
concessions from their own governments
to develop new
cheaper and more fuel-efficient planes
finally there is the fact that the c919
is built mostly on parts made by western
suppliers
engines are the hardest part of the
plane to build and the c919 might still
be a decade away from flying on
chinese-made propulsion
for now it uses engines made by general
electric and safran
the us and the eu don't want to hurt
these companies but geopolitical
tensions
could eventually reach them too china
has already caught up with the west in
many industries
like trains cars and digital technology
so the c919 may be a stepping stone to
posing a real challenge in aerospace as
well
after all the country can potentially
instruct its state-owned airlines to buy
as many homemade planes as it desires